another beautiful night for baseball
as the dodgers and giants meet up in the
middle game of this three-game
series and clayton kershaw and johnny
cueto go head-to-head as the dodgers try
to get their ninth win
out of their last 11 games with austin
slater who's sitting lead off for the
second night in a row
[Applause]
that's lined to center field bellinger
is there
and makes the catch not an easy one
starting with bright sunshine at this
time of night but he brings it in and
slater's the first out
and the base is loaded here in the first
trying to get out of a bases loaded jam
a little jam shot shallow center
hernandez is there and kershaw despite
traffic in the first no damage against
him no scores
on the hill tonight for the giants will
be johnny cueto
the 34 year old right hander 511 230
pounds in his 13th year at the big
league level
still looking for his first win mookie
betts hit a home run in the game last
night
his third of the year
got him a little quick pitch to mookie
betts
you really don't know the effect at a
quick pitch and the shimmy and all the
things that he'll do in his motion
but you don't know how it's going to
affect you now bellinger
lifted out to ustremski in center field
and plato with a one two three first
inning
the rookie catcher chadwick trot
curveball gives him his second kick as
austin slater stands in
lifted out into center field hit pretty
well bellinger back
bellinger at the wall out of here
and the giants take a one-nothing lead i
mean that's right out over the plate
above the belt and that's one you should
do something with
and to slater's credit he gets his first
home run of the year
struck out in the first
yashimsky hits this one high and deep to
right
it is out of here and it's two nothing
giants
his fourth of the year that's just
an unbelievable at bat from yastrimsky
here and is hitting
250 a home run six driven in
high fastball got him
now you see the high target from
chadwick trump and that's right where
johnny cueto gave it to him
austin barnes hitting in the ninth slot
got him so another breaking ball swings
it wide and he gets barnes to chase
heading out of the top of the fourth and
hunter pence
he swings and misses down on strikes
that's three strikeouts in a row for
kershaw
and the first out of the fourth and
here's the eight hitter chadwick trump
kershaw's payoff he gets him swinging
to end the fourth with bookend k's in a
one two three inning
dodgers down two nothing here comes
austin slater
this is hit into center field again
and out of here he's done it again
it's three nothing slaters hit a pair
wow put that on your resume he'll get
you a job his second of the night
his second of the year istremski
a home run in his last outback
lifted out into right center field and
hit pretty well
and it's off the wall coming into score
is solano yustrinski's got another hit
and another rbi and it's four nothing
did he hang in there on that or what
barrels it just gives you an idea how
live this ballpark plays
and he almost knocked it out of here
again lubon's gonna hit
get out to right mookie betts is gonna
make the play
it's gonna knock in pence it's a
sacrifice fly
and it's five nothing and that's a nice
attack
cueto's only allowed one base runner and
that was a walk to chris taylor and
here's
hernandez
[Music]
high the leftie of pence doesn't see it
he does not see it
and it's going to fall behind him
so kk hernandez is going to go to third
and that's the first hit of the game
that's a tough way to lose a no hitter
right there
it is dusk and this is the time when you
are vulnerable
and you cannot catch what you cannot see
now can the dodgers take advantage
barnes with the bouncing ball that'll
bring home the first one for the dodgers
as dubon throws bars out
second run batted in for barnes this
season
now justin turner looking for that first
home run of the season this be a nice
spot for it
turner lifts a fly ball to left field
indeed back towards the royal and
gone it's a new game on turner's first
homerun
three-run shot and it goes from to 5-4
in the blink of an
eye now it's up to aj pollock dodgers
down to their final out
hit out into left field and
that's the ball game well the giants
hang on this was an odd one